hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well st. Anselm of
Canterbury is best known for one main
idea or rather line of argumentation
often called the ontological argument
found in prose loggia and chapter two at
the very least some people want to say
that it continues all the way to chapter
four other people claim to find multiple
ontological arguments in that short
section we don't need to get into that
here and I will say that this line of
argumentation was not called ontological
argument by an Psalm in his own time
even in the Middle Ages even in the
early modern period it waits until the
18th century but then it takes on a life
of its own and there are varieties of
ontological arguments and Psalms
argument that he provides in Chapter two
is not the same as the ontological
argument as we find it in the Cartesian
tradition whether in Rene Descartes or
in Benedict Spinoza or other thinkers
and it's not the same thing as some of
the modern and late modern
reconstructions of the argument by
people like Charles Hartshorn or Norman
Malcolm or any of the contemporary
people who like to talk about perfect
being theology or anything like that
we should look very carefully at what
Ansem himself actually does because his
version of if you want to call it an
ontological argument go ahead is quite
striking because of its starting point
and the fact that as he tells Gunilla I
am NOT using a definition of God as the
starting point for this as many people
took him to be doing so what is this
argument in chapters 2 through 4 and
some is going to prove as you see from
the chapter titles that God exists or is
that God truly is he declared this
intention in what the order of arguments
on the larger argument of the prosto
Gyan is supposed to be doing the single
argument that proves that God exists
that God is the good all other goods
need and everything else that we believe
about God in chapter 3 he argues further
that strictly speaking God cannot even
consistently be thought not to exist and
he ends that chapter actually by
affirming a rather traditional we could
call it plate misconception where God
possesses being to the greatest extent
more than any other being so not only
does God exist God is the greatest being
and God is beyond the being of other
types of beings we don't need to worry
so much about that for the structure in
chapter 2 which is what we're going to
focus on here because that's what most
people and most commentators tend to
look at now the real linchpin of this
comes through a Latin phrase and Ansem
doesn't always use exactly the same
formulation but this is the general way
that he talks about it he calls God quo
Myers Kogut re known potest
sometimes they'll say known volley at
or other things as well Coney Hill my
Coney Hill cocoa powder you meiosis
protest things like that but the general
idea is this that van which there's a
comparative term right my use that then
which nothing greater or that then which
a greater cannot potest known protests
here be thought to exist so whatever
you're thinking of God is greater than
that because God is sort of at the apex
of things and so this is in in some
respects a difficult phrase to wrap your
head around vision well what are you
saying that then which nothing greater
can be thought and notice that it this
can be thought is really central to it
it doesn't just say that which is at the
top of everything that which is greater
than anything else that then which
nothing greater can be thought so it
depends on having thinking things ie
rational beings like us so he begins
chapter two by saying God you know help
me to understand that you are that you
are as we think that you are because you
do have these people and the Bible talks
about the fool saying in his heart there
is no God and he says this not just with
his lips not just aloud but in his heart
he thinks that there is no God and the
fool in the biblical sense is somebody
who could be within the church could be
within the the you know religious
community but they behave in such a way
that they demonstrate that they think
there is no God because they think
there's gonna be no divine you know
punishment for behaving badly or a
reward for doing things well and you
know they're they're affirming a kind of
practical atheism now an some is not so
much worried about the behavior at this
point he's worried about is this a
coherent thought there is no God we know
we can say it right I'm gonna say it all
we want there is no God there is no God
we could make a little song of it if we
- but is it coherent to affirm that
really depends on what we mean by God
now if the fool understands God in a
sort of cartoonish way as this you know
bearded guy up in the sky who throws
down lightning bolts maybe there is no
God maybe that's all BS and maybe the
fool is right about that
but if we understand God in a different
sense if we understand God as that then
which nothing greater can be thought
there's a question about whether that
can be said not to exist so Anselm says
this the fool hears this phrase and
we're going to call it Q quo Maya's
kogatana don't post it right the The
Fool here's Anselm or whoever saying God
is that then which nothing greater can
can be thought right and or that that
then which a greater cannot be thought
so he hears that now the question is
does he registered if he does register
it if he hears it and it's in his
understanding then Q exists in his
understanding and and the fool is
perfectly fine with saying that because
the fool could say yeah I know exactly
what I'm affirming does not exist this
is wonderful you've clarified for me
what I think God who doesn't exist would
be like if God did happen to exist and
handsome uses the example of somebody
who is like a painter maybe the idea of
God is like the idea of a painting he
says what a painter thinks out in
advance what he's going to paint he has
it in his understanding he has it in his
mind in intellect him but he does not
yet understand he doesn't think that it
exists because he's not yet painted it
and as a matter of fact he knows that it
doesn't exist because he hasn't painted
it right so maybe it's like that so he
says even the fool must admit that
something then which nothing greater can
be thought exist at least in his
understanding because he understands
this until you get her a right from
Intel
lactam right he understands this when he
hears it and whatever his understood
exists in the understanding so he's got
the fool now admitting yes okay I get
that cue exists somewhere now the
question is does it exist just in the
understanding and here is this important
distinction between being SN alright in
ant elect them being in the
understanding versus being in reality
esse in ray existing in the world
reality whatever in ray is as opposed to
the understanding you could say that
what Anselm has in mind here is whatever
is not just thought of whatever is not
just imaginary or being conceptualized
but something that has real being so we
have a distinction between two different
kinds of being one is greater and one is
lesser now here's where the argument
really takes a turn if that van which
nothing greater can be thought exists
only in the understanding if this is
something that we say and we hear and we
we grasp it but it doesn't correspond to
anything in reality if it exists only at
the understanding not in reality then we
can think of something greater we can
think of something greater than Q namely
something that does exist in the
understanding or the mind and does exist
in reality
now that produces a problem doesn't it
because what that means is that that
than which nothing greater can be
thought is also at the same time
something than which something else
greater can be thought so it winds up
having contradictory properties as a
matter of fact precisely what we have
taken God is being would have to be
it's opposite God is that then which
nothing greater can be thought and God
is something that a greater can be
thought in relation to so Anselm himself
itself says well that cannot be the case
as a matter of fact the language here is
very interesting and very telling he
says said character Hoke s enone potest
so he's still using this known potest
language right that can't be there is no
possibility of that so what this means
is that Q that then which nothing
greater can be thought exists both in
the intellect and in reality and since Q
is God that means that God no longer or
never did exist just in the intellect
but also exists in reality this is the
conclusion of chapter two and I just
want to point out one thing here he
doesn't he doesn't keep using this term
asked from essa being is the very last
line is existent in or GoPro called do
Bo
so existed a is being used in an
intensive way to connote a greater
degree of being than simply existing in
the mind or perhaps even the essay in in
ray and in the next chapter as I put it
out chapter three and some is actually
going to conclude that one by saying
that God of all things possesses
existence to the highest degree right
and or maxime a omnium habis esta you
have being the most in a way what he's
saying here and this is why you know if
we want to think of this as an argument
for the existence of God it's a little
bit of a strange argument it's not just
that Anselm was already addressing God
so he already believes God exists that
God
or has being or something like that it's
also that this is supposed to show us
how God is that God's being is in some
way necessary and that strictly speaking
it's not even conceivable in a again in
a strict sense that God wouldn't exist
so you can wrap your head around that
and think that through this is I should
point out an argument that anthem
himself or a portion of an argument
rather that anthem himself had to
struggle with quite a bit so it may not
be immediately apparent and it may
strike you as being kind of a sophism
and some himself is convinced that it is
a good line of argumentation whether you
think it is or not whether you think
there are fatal flaws with it you have
to work through it and discern it and as
I often suggest in comments there is no
substitute for reading the text and so
especially with a tricky argument like
this you really want to read the an some
not just look at the summary on a
chalkboard or in a video or podcast
lecturer or something like that that you
want to try to think this through can
that then which nothing greater can be
thought exists only in our minds where
we know that it does exist or does it
have to exist also in reality upon pain
of that reality itself being
contradictory if it doesn't there's a
question to ponder
you